in the last video we talked about how
humans over time have gotten better and
better at getting more calories out of a
given unit of land and one thing i do
want to emphasize in the last video
these numbers that i came up with i
picked these numbers to make the math
fairly simple and to give you the
general idea i don't want you to
think that the most that a a square
kilometer can support today is exactly
1000 people it depends usually on what
the land is like how much of the land
you're actually using for agriculture
what crops you're planting etc etc how
the people are living how many calories
they need
the whole point of the last video was
just to give you a framework that wow
there is this upper bound based on how
much productivity you actually get from
the land now what we want to think about
in this video that was kind of the last
video was this axis right here getting
more and more out of the land what i
want to think about in this video is how
did humans through different
technologies how did we get by doing
less and less of the labor for getting
those calories out of the land obviously
you just don't have land and and things
spontaneously grow well i guess that
would happen in the wild but if you're
doing agriculture you need to put some
energy into the land you got to you got
to work the land and so what we have
over here in this chart and this chart
is derived from information from this
book right over here this is energy and
society
and what we want to think about here is
the different ways that humans have gone
about to till soil so we're not even
going to think about the total process
or the total energy required to grow a
certain crop
what we're just going to focus is one
step of the agricultural process and
that is tilling the soil and in case
you're like me and you have never worked
on a farm which one that's one thing i
would like to change one day is actually
go through that process but tilling the
soil is kind of churning it up so you
get the nutrients from the bottom layers
to the surface you dig you you bury all
of the remains from the last harvest you
bury all of the all of the uh all of the
weeds so that they die and you also kind
of get air in the soil what it does is
essentially prepares the soil for the
next for the next agricultural cycle so
it's a process that that humans have
been doing since antiquity and what i
want to do in this video is think about
the different ways to do it and how much
energy is required to do it and we're
going to think about the energy in two
ways how much of that energy comes from
humans and how much how much of that
energy comes from things other than
humans so just as an example when we
talk about human power we're talking
about someone literally hand plowing
this field so this this woman right over
here is literally she has this little
cart that's digging up the soil behind
her when we talk about oxen power we're
talking about the oxen
doing most of the work they're the ones
dragging this plow which is digging up
all of the soil and this gentleman has
to kind of be there to supervise but
there still is a good there still is
fairly intense labor that this this
gentleman is doing right over here and
then when we talk about tractors we're
talking about a scenario like this where
the tractor is doing most of the work of
actually digging up dragging this plow
behind it and digging up all of the soil
and from this book right over here
that's where we got these numbers i'll
tell you which numbers i got from them
and which numbers i kind of
kind of reason through because i wasn't
fully comfortable with the numbers that
they had but these are their numbers
that if your human power to till
one hectare of soil it'll take 400 hours
oxen power and this should be a pear not
a parry that should be a pair of oxen 65
hours a six horsepower tractor 25 hours
a 50 horsepower tractor four hours and
in case y'all are wondering what is a
hectare of soil it is literally a plot
of land
a hectare of soil let me write it a
hectare
of a hectare of land i should say is a
plot of land that is 100 meters by 100
meters and it's roughly it's roughly
equal to two and a half acres not
exactly two and a half acres it's like
2.4 i think 2.47 something
but roughly two and a half acres so
we're just thinking about how much how
many hours to essentially dig up all of
the soil for a plot of land 100 by 100
meters
so what we have over here so clearly
human takes a lot longer oxen they can
do a little bit faster six horsepower
tractor even faster 50 horsepower
tractor very powerful tractor even
faster than that now this column right
over here is the machine the amount of
energy required to actually produce and
maintain the machinery use so this is a
very unintuitive thing whenever you
think about whenever like for example
whenever you think about the amount of
energy to to plow this land over here
you you tend to think okay well this
this individual is going to have to
expend a lot of her energy you don't
think about the amount of energy
required to actually maintain the tool
to one build the
the the tool that she's using in this
case a hand plow and then to maintain
that as she does it and so this estimate
and i got these two from the these
fellows right over here actually one of
them might be a gal
but it's about 6000 kilocalories and
this is k this is kilocalories for
lowercase c and one thing i want to
emphasize here
one
k c a l is equal to is the same thing as
one calorie with a capital c which is
the same thing as 1000 calories with a
lowercase c and we talked about this in
the last video but these
when people talk about food calories
they're really talking about a calorie
with a capital c or you could say
they're talking about kilocalories so
your candy bar 200 calories they're
talking about this right over here in
chemistry class when you talk about the
amount of energy to raise a gram of
water one degree celsius you were
talking about these calories here so in
all of these numbers in this chart right
over here they are in either you can
either view them as this unit kcals
kilocalories or calories with a capital
c they're essentially the same units
that we used in the last video and these
are the same numbers that you were used
to from a kind of a dietary calorie
point of view
so for example 6 000 calories that's
about how much a typical male would
expend in three days so this is to
maintain it over the course of these 400
hours in the case of the hand plow and
the total amount of calories
the total amount of calories that were
needed to make the plow divided by the
total number of hours so whatever
fraction of the plows life is being used
here you use that fraction right over
here to put this 6 000 calories but
needless to say for at least the plow
for the kind of the the either the human
or the oxen scenario this isn't a
significant amount of the total calories
so obviously if you're doing it either
with human power or oxen power you're
not using any gasoline you're not using
any petroleum in all of these scenarios
we're going to assume that someone has
10 working hours in the day and that
right over here where this is kind of a
measure of how hard that person's work
is and i i kind of estimated these
numbers here they're slightly different
than what what the original numbers were
in this book right over here
but we're saying look if you are
actually walking along using this hand
plow that is actually very very
vigorous activity so it is going to
require about 400 calories per hour to
do this type of activity you do it over
10 hours it's going to require 4 000
calories just to do that over 10 hours
and then we're assuming that there's
some rest that the rest of the day
you're going to walk around maybe you're
going to cook dinner eat breakfast
you're going to sleep some of it we're
assuming that the other 14 hours of the
day are going are going to be at about
100 calories per hour and so this is the
total if someone were to using this
technique work for a total of 10 hours
this is how many calories they would
consume in the day and you can see this
is the most labor intensive so it looks
like that they would consume the most
calories per day this is these two are
the least labor intensive you're sitting
on a tractor although that still
requires more calories than sleeping or
watching tv and so that's the number of
calories they would consume now this
right over here and this is the
interesting number or one of the really
interesting numbers based on all of
these assumptions this is the total
human input in calories to do this task
to till this one hectare of soil
so over here you're using 5 400 calories
a day if you're working 10 hours per day
and it requires 400 total hours you're
going to be working 40 days right 400
divided by 10. 40 days times 5400
calories per day you're going it's going
to take a human it's going to take a
human just the human part not even
thinking about the 6 000 calories
necessary to maintain and make that plow
is the human is going to spend 216 000
calories to till to plow that one
hectare of land and if you add the other
six thousand in to for the actual plow
and you can debate what this number
should be but it's not a significant
number compared to this you get about
222 000 total calories when you go to
the oxen situation you're requiring
fewer hours and each hour it requires a
fewer
a little less calories this is this is
still labor intensive but not as labor
intensive as what this woman right over
here is doing so on a daily basis you're
using a few a little bit fewer calories
but since you're only doing six and a
half days of this 65 hours divided by 10
you have you've significantly reduced
the number of calories the total number
of calories that the human needs to put
into this task now there still is other
energy being done now all of a sudden
the oxen have gotten involved and if you
assume that each oxen consumes about 20
000 calories a day and you have two of
them so 40 000 calories per day for just
to feed the oxen
and you're going to do that for six and
a half days 65 divided by 10. the oxen
are going to consume 260 000 calories to
do this task so the total energy input
here now is has gone up so this is an
interesting phenomenon that is going on
right over here what the human is
putting in as we get better and better
technology goes down substantially 216
000 to 33 000 and we'll see what the
tractor it goes down even more but the
total energy if you if you include the
amount of energy that the oxen have to
put in or if you include the amount of
energy due to the gasoline that has to
be used for the tractor the total amount
of energy is going up to plow that field
but the human energy goes down
dramatically now the last thing i want
to highlight here and these are where my
numbers
depart a little bit or fairly
significantly from this original study
right over here these are this original
estimate is the machinery input on the
tractors so if you look this up and you
can google search it they have much
larger numbers here but i did a little
research and it looks like for most
petroleum-based combustion based engines
or vehicles roughly 20 percent of the
total energy that's used in fuel 20
percent of that energy is used for the
actual production and maintenance of
that vehicle over its life so what we
did over here is we said okay for a six
horsepower tractor i use their numbers
where you're going to have to use 25
hours to do it it's going to use this
much petroleum assuming that it uses
23.5 liters of gas or petroleum over 25
hours and then i just 20 of that number
for saying well how much of how much how
much energy had to be used to maintain
that vehicle over over that amount of
time and if you think about what
fraction of this vehicle's life that 25
hours represents that fraction times the
total amount of energy required to
produce that so remember these things
are made out of metal they had to be
made in furnaces so just producing a
vehicle requires a lot of energy and so
this is this right over here is 20
and i just use that rule of thumb
for most petroleum-based or
combustion-based vehicles the 20 of the
total energy expenditure over the course
of the that vehicle's life it was is
roughly is roughly equal to the amount
of energy used to
produce that vehicle but either way you
go all the way over here the human has
to spend less calories sitting on the
vehicle so they spend less calories per
day
and then the total human input right
over here for the six horsepower tractor
it's going to take them two and a half
days 25 hours at 10 hours a day is going
to be 8 500 calories but of course you
have the petroleum used and then some
estimate of the amount of energy used to
produce that tractor and you're just
taking the fraction over that 25 hours
you're not taking the entire life of
that six horsepower tractor to produce a
six horsepower tractor this number would
be much much larger if you talked about
the total number of energy we're just
taking the small fraction of its life
that we're using it right over here same
thing for the 50 horsepower tractor but
either any way you look at it the human
the and this is the really interesting
thing humans by going from human power
all the way to a 50 horsepower tractor
you're getting almost a factor of 200
improvement in terms of how little
energy has to be put in by the human to
till that land but you actually get a
total increase if you factor in things
like the petroleum and then definitely
the the machine the amount of energy to
actually produce that machine so anyway
hopefully you found that interesting
i find this i know kind of it's
something that you don't think a lot
about how much energy input has to be
put in and and oftentimes we we only
think about the human energy input but
we're not thinking about the energy
input from other things like like oxen